the president is said to be considering
putting Venezuela on the list of Nations
designated as state sponsors of
terrorism coupon a Kevin Cork reports
tonight from West Palm Beach where the
president just touched down on why
Venezuela and why now it would be the
strongest signal yet that the Trump
administration is willing to target the
oil-rich but faltering South American
country The Washington Post citing
unnamed sources says the Trump
administration is prepared to add
Venezuela to its list of state sponsors
of terrorism a designation reserved for
governments accused of repeatedly
providing support for acts of
international terrorism and includes
Iran North Korea Sudan and Syria though
it has yet to confirm the report the
White House does have strong support
from Republicans on Capitol Hill to hit
the renegade Maduro regime with one of
its most powerful tools in a letter
penned by Florida Senator Marco Rubio
and fellow GOP senators John Cornyn of
Texas and Colorado's Cory Gardner
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is urged
to quote protect the American homeland
and our people from the Venezuelan
dictatorships egregious support for
terrorism and narco trafficking citing
the ongoing nature of the discussion
White House officials refused to say
whether or not the designation was a
foregone conclusion but an NSC spokesman
noted that the administration will
consider scalable options to pressure
the Maduro regime to restore democracy
in venezuela under Maduro Venezuela has
suffered hyperinflation food shortages
and a devastating measles outbreak which
because of emergency migration has now
spread into neighboring countries Brazil
Argentina Colombia Ecuador and Peru
critics questioned the wisdom of
applying even more pressure on a
regional powder-keg looks like just an
expression of anger
that will not achieve any of our goals
and will make life work worse for the
average venezuelan the State Department
has apparently asked HHS the Department
of Homeland Security as well as the CDC
and USAID for input on that terror
designation Brett the question being can
the u.s. hit Maduro without causing
further hardships for the Venezuelan
people right Kevin cork outside the
winter white house in Palm Beach Kevin
thanks